et maintenant les bizarres mais thomas
domingo
ce tour
si l'homme véritable 6 juillet
à
c'est bien j'ai dû gagner laurent baffie
genre d'armes en méfiez vous de gérard
darmon
méfiez-vous du jardin emile ntamack je
te propose comme le contact le passe
bien qu'ils étaient grillés l'affairé si
on était de changer si tu veux un
ah oui parce qu'elle est avec christophe
donc tout cela dit des conneries sans
intérêt jesse charbonnier gars parce que
la prise je vais parler de la vie privée
de notre amie julie et franchement ça
nous laisse peu d'espoir mon cher
d'armand je te garantis alors julie
gayet donc on vous a vu depuis dix ans
dans une vingtaine de films dont les
deux papa et la maman delphine 1 yvan 0
les gens qui s'aiment de tâches est là
mais on vous connaît mal
on vous connaît assez mal vous êtes sans
doute trop discrète je sais pas sinon
ouais super bien on a fait un bien tu
vas nous parler d'elle alors que celle
très discrète on sait rien et moi je
suis très peu de choses sur elle si
c'est une fille et charmante excellente
comédienne b mère de famille mariée là
et c'est ça le problème et donner un
label et puis c est là c'est une
comédienne qui est capable de venir avec
son costume de deux films en oeuvre les
rita est là ce soir effectivement ans
rita comme dans le film en temps à
parler alors mère de famille
effectivement vous croyez à l'amour
c'est bien vos parents c'est un peu
comme les miens à vos parents chaque
mois les parents ils sont mariés depuis
je peux quand même temps 55 ans et
continue à se faire des bisous à se
tenir la main pour regarder la télé font
des câlins c'est pareil les vôtres c'est
un rêve c'est génial c'est un bel
exemple cette année ramage barreda pas
d'y faire ma vie non mais c'est vrai
c'est un exemple ça quand on s'attendait
à ça devant les yeux après ça revient
sur un ca n gérard tu vois toi quoi va
voir quoi moi quoi quand on est un
exemple comme ça dans les yeux après
jamais cet exemple et ses cinq enfants
ensemble ça rien fait
mais si c'est un fake quand on accouche
marché quoi bah tiens quand même à
marcher sur julie ça marche pour le sang
vous êtes très sexy halle à l'arrivée on
le blé rita a été magnifique j'étais
assez sous le charme et vous aimez pas
tellement en fait je suis pas souvent
comme cela oui moi je vous aime comme ça
c'est pour moi si même émotion
vous avez une certaine gêne à poser nu
vous raconter qu'une fois vous étiez aux
beaux-arts vous posiez nu aux beaux-arts
le premier jour tout s'est bien passé je
devais faire un film je tairai poser nue
et justement pour pas avoir de gêne et
parce que c'est un travail je me suis
dit ben alors allons-y
je suis allé poser aux beaux-arts je me
suis rendu compte que quand tout le
monde travaille voilà n'ont pas bien et
quand y en a un qui commence à mattel
sont tout de suite mais un regard un
faux pas mates et accomplir man show pas
ma thèse est difficile c'est vrai vous
avez demandé à tous les gens qui étaient
sur le plateau de se déshabiller parce
que ça on le voit leur nom parce que
justement il y avait des producteurs qui
est là et qui te veux pas être là 1 vous
faites respecter quoi c'est vrai qu'en
tant que producteur quand il ya une
scène de nu tu vas sur le tournage je
je confirme que ce jour là tu t'es tu
viens voir comment ça se passe va très
bien c'est bien un conducteur ni alors
dans le film dont on parle là vous êtes
tenus c'est déjà une vraie raison elle
voit pas beaucoup d'entrées alors ça
s'appelle la vérité à sainte patronne
des cas désespérés de stéphane clavier
avec son frère christian clavier vous
connaissez les sans clavier ou litres il
est nu dans le film avec arielle
dombasle eddy mitchell pierre mondy
marthe villalonga jean claude dreyfus ça
sort le 24 septembre
alors effectivement donc le grand moment
mois pour moi je sais quand vous matin
vous baigner nu sur la plage là c'est
quoi ces camps bien s'annoncer c'est
qu'on s'est ridiculisé les nuances ariel
se penche sur demande si c'est un
mouchoir une matraque adrénaline ses
plus grands tubes et casse pour la vous
enlevez votre perruque dont je vous dis
franchement les cheveux voilà à quoi ils
aiment les scories bénichou libraires
alors on fait le pitch julie 10 ans et
christian clavier qui est expert
comptable
la porte bien mais la placidité de ce
garçon sait voir un beau gosse 1 1
il s'en fout là ducharme lui avec ou
sans perruque façon et la page des
gonzesses il s'en fout complètement il
va faire un tour de table il est
toujours bien laurent enfin toyota
alors on fait le pitre jean christian
clavier et experts comptables sur la
côte d'azur il fait 1 1 ou 10 dans un
chantier naval dirigé par eddy mitchell
et arielle dombasle et après cet audit
il décide de s'offrir une nuit de rêve
dans un palace cannois et sur l'internet
il trouve une créature de rêve qui n'est
autre que julie gayet enfin ce qui s'est
passé que ces nuits va virer au
cauchemar
ce quand il arrive dans la cité niçoise
où elle habite versa vous me pourris
c'est le pitch et tu continuer ces
manifs on arrive dans la cité jeu c'est
pour toi que je fais c'est et moi je
trouve que c'est un vrai métier je pense
que quand il arrive dans la cité niçoise
il a trouvé avec un cadavre elle le bras
pour regarder qui la débarrasse de ce
cas là voilà c'est l'avenir c'est
l'histoire c'est fabuleux
c'est l'histoire voilà alors maintenant
je vais arrêter de bosser parce que
c'est insupportable
j'essaye d'aider m
le temps n'a rien donné personne n'a dit
bonjour antoine voilà alors maintenant
julie c'est vous qui allez bosser parce
que moi j'en peux plus vous avez deux
minutes chrono pour convaincre les gens
d'aller voir ce film
attention certes je pourrais mettre une
caméra assure julie dédié et démarrer un
chronomètre pour deux minutes top chrono
fin pourquoi il fallait voir ce film je
crois il va les faire c'est finement et
15 secondes et je préfère tout ce que
vous voulez je suis même refaire une
scène de baignade pourquoi il fallait
voir ces films pourquoi il fait ça finit
qu'est-ce qu'on peut chanter je fais
déjà quitté d'acteurs exceptionnels
louis pasquet christian qui c'est une
comédie qui est jubilatoire qu'il est
rock'n'roll que moi je joue une espèce
de jean reno féminin guy lebrac est
comparé dans une aventure moi j'ai
jamais joué un rôle concret d'une
héroïne centre chez pas la panthère rose
et moi j'avais besoin d'être plutôt
manara que même à écriture de buffy ça
marche
j'ai lu votre vente à tout le monde va y
aller
attention au micro que vous enlevez en
même temps que la baisse mais je pense
que la méline occupez vous de cette
demoiselle tout le monde d'aller voir le
film vous êtes en train de vous allez
voir son film
ça fait une minute il vous reste il vous
reste une minute
voilà niveau est une minute julien de
moody's et de perdre 50 secondes une
minute parce que enlève le tissu cap tà
4 backup
je suis pas dans un jeu d'enfant ce film
c'est vrai qu'en france je sais j'ai
bien tenté thierry pick up sont rappelés
bon alors il reste rome se dit pascal
réel parce que c'est une comédie parce
qu'on part dans une aventure parce que
moi je me suis éclaté alors sérieusement
pourquoi
ouais parce que stéphane clavier a fait
une lumière à tomber pour une comédie
qu'on que si voilà il ya une bonne
lumière dans celui-là une info 19 c'est
déjà une belle vue sur 4 3 2 que je te
malheureuse de christian clavier a avec
une belle lumière